hello my name is Dave Nielsen I work at
Redis labs I'd like to just start off by
getting some things out of the way such
as I just started so I'm still learning
quite a bit however I have focused on
this particular topic so I can give a
good presentation around this topic but
if you're looking for advanced Redis
conversation I'm just not going to be
able to do that today however maybe
someday in the future a couple of things
is Retta slabs and Rattus are not the
same
Retta slabs as a company separate from
the open-source project it does not own
the open-source project so I just want
to make sure that's very clear and
finally this is just a talk about open
source Redis although I might mention
our company and other companies once in
a while but it's not a pitch or
promotion of bonus labs so we're going
to talk everything I say here is about
open source Redis I do have t-shirts so
if you stick around towards the end I
can give you a couple well one each but
I've got one for all of you if you want
one also I took a lot of the content for
this talk from a book called Redis in
action
by Josiah Karim Carlson that's right
and I met him down in Los Angeles not
too long ago super bright guy if you
ever want the book is actually mostly
free online at Redis labs comm slash
Academy so you can go read it there he's
got a PhDs wickedly smart does not work
for Redis Labs just happens to have
partnered with us to promote this book
so let's go ahead and get started now
what I want to do is to give you an idea
about what Redis is and we'll give you
some use cases that's the primary focus
of this talk I don't know if I'll go the
full full-time but we'll see how long it
goes so first of all what is Redis Redis
is an open source in memory no SQL
database it was created roughly around
2009 by a guy named Salvatore Sanfilippo
he's out of Sicily Italy and he's done
amazing work but
not the only one he's also got a crew of
folks who work with him you know in the
open-source community he did just
recently joined Redis labs so you know
that's obviously a vote of confidence
for us but he's still working on
open-source Redis so he's not actively
working on our products or anything like
that you know uh Redis is known for
being wickedly fast it is a very very
fast in memory database and that's what
most people think of it as being very
very fast cash and it's also a database
so it's both of those things so what can
you do with Redis so again like I said a
lot of people think of it as a cache
that means you might already have a
database like MongoDB or sequel server
or MySQL or something like that and
there's certain parts of your website or
your application that need to get at
that data more quicker than then your
database is able to respond and so you
might put some of that data in memory as
a cache so Redis is used primarily in
that way but it's not just a cache where
you take and put strings whoo it's also
a cache that's kind of funny let me flip
over here okay it's also a cache where
you can put data structures so it has
strings list sets sorted sets and hashes
plus some additional data types like a
bit Mac and bitmap in a hyper log-log
which we will talk about a little bit
further
it has 160 commands - so sometimes you
need to make a transaction or something
well there's a whole bunch of custom
specialized commands that you can do
with Redis where it's created these
commands are created specifically to be
high performant so instead of writing
your code that gets the data brings it
back does something and then sends the
data back to Redis it just you send the
data in a function call and it does all
the work on the server very very fast if
you need to do something custom where
you want something to be done very very
fast on the server you can use Lua
scripts Lua scripts are a is its own
programming language but it compiles
into memory so your
leaving Redis to go do the work it's
actually all done in memory on the same
server there's lots of different use
cases I'm going to go through some of
these use cases but you know you can
store your sessions in Redis you can
keep a list of most recent visitors you
can compare which one of your friends
are my friends you can do pub/sub
there's there's lots and lots of
examples so who uses Redis tons of
companies all these companies you know
of they all use Redis it's incredibly
fast and if you have lots of people
hitting your website you know you can
cache that data but if you want to do
something that's interactive or
something where they're getting the most
recent let's say post to website like
what Twitter does that needs to be done
more in a structured way and Redis is
perfect for that
so Instagram Pinterest tumblr Craigslist
Stack Overflow github even docker uses
it to host all that data about their
docker images up on docker hub I'm sort
of funny joke the most difficult
engineering job in the world is the
engineers at Stack Overflow
because when Stack Overflow goes down
they can't use Stack Overflow to
troubleshoot the problem all right so
all right who contributes to write a
whole bunch of people but its primary
primarily Salvatore however you know
there are is a long tail of folks out
there who contribute you can see this is
just a kind of a chart of contributions
over time so it's been fairly consistent
in growing a little bit over time but
you know the products very mature now so
they're adding functionality but if I I
think it's only if they're there it's it
feels like they're only adding things
that are going to help make it faster or
you know some edge cases but the primary
functionality seems to be there so where
can you get Redis so you can go get it
from the open source download off of
github there's also a Redis do it's a
great resource for Redis if you're
looking to get started there's a lot of
material there documentation at Redis do
if you want enterprise cluster rattus
labs company I work for offers that you
can get a free download you can also use
Redis cloud also by our company this is
Redis as a service upon Amazon on Azure
on Google on IBM's clouds so we run it
in all of those clouds and there's lots
of other companies out there so you can
go to read a screen open Redis again
Redis cloud and read us to go these are
all different rhetta's as a service
providers even Amazon ElastiCache is
based on Redis so and as yours cache is
also based on reddit so Retta so again
let's go into some details here so you
know what is Redis so very specifically
some people you've probably heard the
term you know key value store so Redis
isn't really a traditional key value
where the value is a string it's would
call a key data structures server or
store and what that means is it has more
than just string values that get stored
in cache you can store data that's more
like a database and there's different
types of data types data values so you
can have strings lists sets sorted sets
and hashes the hash is kind of like a
hash table so that's very similar to a
table you can also have bitmaps in
memory and there's something called a
hyper log log which I'll talk about
briefly it's kind of a new thing
it runs in memory as I said before which
means it's extremely fast both for reads
and writes and it does have disk
persistence so you can have a log and
you can capture the data so that you're
storing it on disk and therefore if
something were to happen it goes down
you can survive the crash it'll load
back up for you and your because it all
only runs in memory your limitation
primarily is the memory available on
that particular server you can cluster
Redis you can do it with the open-source
version however if you need help or if
you feel like you just rather have
somebody provide you the technology that
does all that that's what our company
does
but let's move on to how Redis is used
so it's like I said it's extremely easy
to use it's very well-documented up on
rehto scott io so you know go take a
look there's lots of good useful
information there most people use it as
a cache or as a second database so if
you've got a database on your server
that's saving your data on disk but you
are having problems scaling that you can
use Redis not only to cache but also to
keep the data from the database in
memory so you can query it and some
folks actually do use it as a
first-class database and in other words
you don't have another database this is
their only database usually you might do
that if the data that you're keeping in
your database isn't very useful after a
short period of time like for example on
high-frequency trading or something like
that where all the data is really
happening in real time and you know
maybe you stream it off and store it
somewhere as a log but you don't really
need to keep that data if we're to go
down it wouldn't be useful to bring it
back up because time is already passed
so who is using Redis there's a lot of
different companies I mentioned before
you can go take a look at this URL and
see tons of companies using it and by
the way oh I forgot to mention it's also
great for other things like pub/sub a
lot of folks user for pub/sub so what
that means is you have a lot of web
browsers open and they're all viewing a
shared set of data then you can have
them subscribe to Redis which will then
let them know when a change occurs and
they can all update their browsers
simultaneously I've actually written an
application and using node.js for that
and there's a configuration file that
you set up it's really simple so it's
actually quite simple to set up
individually it's also single threaded
this is kind of interesting so what that
means is it's only doing one action at a
time so accuse them all up and it does
them all on in a row this actually helps
with performance because you don't have
to worry about a record being locked
it's just doing one action after another
there is no locking because of that so
and it's
lightning fast that it actually is quite
hard to give it so many requests that it
can't handle the load although you can
that can't happen so it's it's
incredibly fast and the single foot it
actually helps with that which this
means though is you tend to shard if you
run out of memory you need more space
you tend to shard your database so you
might have transactions A through F on
this database on the server you know G
through I don't know m on this server
and n through Z on another server so
that's that might be typically how you
were to scale and okay so I mentioned
earlier or maybe I didn't but anyway
it's it's often compared to memcache D
Redis actually supports memcache D for
the most part so a lot of folks actually
have used them cache D might switch over
to Redis because they got they get the
MM cached memcache D functionality plus
the Redis functionality and it's just as
fast as memcache D for most in most
cases and again you get this rich set of
data not just key value pairs you get to
store data in a structure so you can do
querying in memory and it does support
persistence so you know if your server
goes down you don't have to your server
might have to come back up or you can
recover from another server but you can
recover all the memory at once you don't
have to wait for it to rebuild which can
be very slow and painful and it does
replication through a master slave
concept so you can have a set of your
data in memory on one server it can keep
a copy in another server that means if
when if your primary server were to go
down it can immediately switch over to
use the copy and then therefore you
don't have any downtime and in a very
common scenario you would actually have
a master slave scenario where the master
is doing all the interacting with your
applications and the slave is actually
doing this saving to disk so they both
have their their role and you can
perform better that way so what are some
more use cases oops somehow we lost air
we go okay that's funny so what are some
use cases um
one example is you might show the last
items listed on a website on your
webpage you know eBay postings are
listing something like that obviously at
some point you need to remove them so
you'd have delete deleting or filtering
based on certain criteria you do that -
that would be hard to do in a cache
where there's no idea of individual
records that are in a set a leaderboard
actually makes a lot of sense with Redis
so you might have a bunch of users all
competing and then based on criteria you
can very quickly and easily filter that
data and show you know the top players
of all time top players this month top
players today top players right now all
that could be in memory and sorted
quickly and displayed in real time also
user voting you can use a sorted set
which I'll talk about a little bit where
you can let people vote and then you've
got your names of people or ideas or
products or whatever you're voting on
and then your votes that can all be kept
in memory in real time and you can
expire items so for example this is
great for things where you know that you
don't want that information to display
after a certain period of time you can
set an expiration date on the record and
then it will automatically you don't
have to go back and remove it it'll
automatically remove itself from the
list and therefore automatically stop
displaying on the webpage at that time
so a lot of very useful functions now
I've got more for you counting stuff
that's probably pretty easy to do unique
items so they've got some functionality
where you can say add this to the list
but only if it doesn't exist on the list
already and you don't have to worry
about writing that functionality right
it's just does that for you so that way
you can keep it unique without any
effort you can do real real time
analysis for what's going on so if you
want to add any information like maybe
you're keeping track of bugs from an API
so as an API comes in every time there's
a a you know error message or or
actually all responses you can you just
log them all in memory and then in real
time you're keeping track of all of that
activity
and it's all quickly available from your
dashboard to see you know what are the
top error messages that kind of thing
like I said you can use it for pub/sub
it's also great for queues
there's functionality where you can pass
in them you can pass it in from you can
make a request using a function that
says remove an item from this queue and
put it into this queue and it will do
them if effectively in a transaction
because again it's all serial so we'll
do that all in one action and therefore
you know that that information will get
moved from one Ida one cue to the other
without losing data so a lot of
high-performance operations like that
and like I said before caching caching
is like extremely popular with Redis and
you know but I don't want you to think
of it it just just a cache but it is a
very very good cache so the key takeaway
from looking at these particular use
cases is that you with with high speed
data where you're trying to keep your
website responding to really unusual
usage patterns that your database wasn't
really designed for rather than trying
to model something very cleverly so that
you can take your model and mirror it on
the website and keep updating your model
to match the performance required the
best probable scenario is just simply
take the data keep it the way it's
stored the way you need it to be stored
in your own system but then remodel it
using something like Redis and just put
it in a way that it's going to perform
better for your website and you can you
know you can take in each individual use
case and customize it for that
particular scenario so that it performs
quickly and don't worry about changing
your own model you can combine these
these functions together to get what you
need and because it does the work for
you you don't have to write your own
code which is most likely not going to
be as fast so instead you can call the
function have all the work done on the
server and then you're done rather than
getting the data pulling it
back doing the work that you need to be
done and then resubmitting it to the
database that's not likely to be as fast
so there's a bunch of data types I don't
have a I don't have a any much more than
this so I'm going to go through some
data types for you and then we'll be
done so let's just take a quick look you
got your string okay it's more or less
what you think it might be you can store
a lot up to 512 megabytes in one string
and it's ideal for all sorts of things
you can do Jason you can store your data
as JSON in a string just like you would
MongoDB or something like that you can
store little bits of data for real-time
metrics or like I said like active users
you might just store that in a string
and just keep that in string instead of
a table you can store binary files so if
you're actually serving images you can
keep that in memory as well here's some
examples of some functions and these
cases you know like you can do a lot of
thoughts stuff with this for example you
can actually tell a record that you want
it to not change like set that value and
it it can't change nothing can change it
and then after a period of time it will
either automatically delete or then
become changeable again you can use it
for a cache you can put up images and
then you can have you can actually write
over the image you know put words or
something like that over that image and
that let users download that data
without having to save it down to disk
so that can be very quick you can use it
for just simple things like a be testing
and so that it's not you know you're not
having to save a bunch of data you just
kind of look at who's coming in figure
out oh it's this session we'll do this
test so keep some flags in memory that
kind of thing lots of different use
cases where you just don't need to go
put all this in your database lists so
these are just internally maintained as
link lists they're extremely fast
especially towards the beginning in the
end of the list so you know very long
lists and you can use this again for
like queues or just stacks of data top
and recent news that
thing and this is what a lot of folks
use for social networks so this is what
you know Twitter uses you know pretty
much all those social websites are using
this functionality and use for for
logging users actions this are pop
l.push is what I talked about earlier
where you can kind of take an item out
of a queue and stick it in another queue
all in one function we also have sets
sets is just simply a unique list so you
throw some data in there if it's already
in there I just ignores it it doesn't
add it again or you can use sets to
compare one set with another set so
you're friends with my friends we can
very quickly figure out which friends we
have in common you can find out you know
hey here's a here's does this number
already exist that kind of thing lots of
very simple but very highly effective
and fast functionality again it's great
for storing social data here are some
functions oops that kind of got whacked
out so you've got some tracking IP
tracking IP unique IPS to your website
so if for example if you're trying to
defend against the DDoS or something
like that you can use this functionality
to say you know what I've gotten too
many requests from this website in the
short period of time you can set the
automatically expire so that you can set
it off it you know 10 seconds or
something like that and if if a person
keeps coming back more than two or three
times per 10 seconds you might decide
that's something unusual you know used
to tagging information creating random
numbers so you can respond for ads or
lottery information tips of the day that
kind of stuff that's all great for in
memory let's try that page is a little
off you can a sorted set a sorted sets
kind of interesting because you can add
a value to the number or
a value to the data so this is how you
would keep track of like if people are
voting and you have a value next to the
list of data and therefore you can have
a sorted vote on a sorted list
essentially our sorted set and basically
it's behaves just like sets except for
you have that that value next to it and
it's still extremely fast and the the
the queries are very fast because it all
the sorting happens immediately upon
insert so the queries are always going
against static data it's very fast and
again for using examples like a
leaderboard top lists of anything you
can index other data so if you have hash
tables or other lists you can index them
using a sorted set that references off
to another structured type you can click
for example querying for a range of
users all given a date or age or some
other characteristic and finally of the
five main types you got the hash and
hash is kind of like a table very
similar to a table and so you've got the
value like a unique user ID and then you
got all the additional values that are
stored along with it it's you can kind
of nest one hash within another but then
that's about as far as you can go and
you can refer to each one of the values
individually and you can even sort them
so it can behave more or less like a
regular table this is where you would
store data if you're storing data for
for example in a business object for
example you know like maybe a person and
their characteristics or you know an
automobile in there and its
characteristics you can store all that
in a hash and you can keep track of many
to many mappings that way and there's a
couple last a couple of bonus types
there's a bit maps and hyper log log so
as I mentioned earlier you can store
image
memory and then manipulate them in
memory and there are operations
specifically for that like it up where
you can take a particular range of
pixels within a range and update them or
edit them and like I said before you can
use this for putting text over an image
all doing that in memory and then not
having to say that to disk because you
may not need to do that I might just be
on the fly and then the hyper log log is
kind of interesting it is a what they
call a probabilistic cardinality
estimator it's a mouthful what that
really means is you can can out you can
count a value within a larger string or
sets of strings statistically so you've
got you know perhaps millions of
webpages all with data on it and you
want to know how many times does a
particular word show up in those
millions of webpages
well rather than keeping all of that
data in memory what happens is you can
iterate through all the data and then
the hyper log log will will estimate
will keep a track of an estimate of how
many times the words show up so that
you're not having to keep everything in
memory in order to find that out this
would be very useful for example when
you do a search on Google and you were
to do a search for Redis it would tell
you how many times reddit shows up on
webpages it's not actually doing an
accurate count of that in real time it's
getting an estimate so it's similar to
that so I'm going to start wrapping
things up here I've got this like I said
there's a lot of information that I got
is from the book right as an action you
can go check it out at Redis Labs comm
slash I kind of spelled that wrong but
Academy and then also a couple of things
just to mention I'll be back I'll be
back up here in just a few weeks for
something called the container day which
is actually hopping at night in Seattle
so if you're interested I can also get
you a 30% off the Linux con conference
that's going on so if you're into Linux
or anything like that you can go to the
conference for 30% off but the event I'm
putting on is free and you can
check it out it's August 16th downtown
Seattle you can find out more the
Twitter handle container day and that's
about it so I can take questions I also
have some shirts and I think that's
about it so yeah that's it so if you
have any questions like I said I'm
fairly new but I can get some answers if
I don't know the answer so when we start
with you in the back yes you can now
like for example on Amazon or Azure
where you have availability zones those
are probably close enough or something
where the time to replicate is is
reasonable but like cross continent or
around the world replication would be
potentially problematic depending on how
fast you're updating the data but yes
you can do that yeah actually there is
an open-source version it's fairly new
but if you go to get download Redis 3.0
whatever the three recent most most
recent 3 point version is it does have
clustering in there so you can try that
and you know it's it's the open-source
version and then yeah and then Redis
labs provides a supported version that's
more based on proprietary clustering
that we've created it is not the same as
the open-source version yeah
yeah typically what will happen and you
know again
well okay typically what will happen is
you would set up Redis so that you're
installing multiple Redis databases one
per core and then you would basically
chart across that that's how you would
handle that okay Ivy is thread this is
available for measure subscription so
that's a good question that I haven't
looked at myself so I don't know I do
know that somebody said that it would be
a good topic for hey webinar or a talk
to talk about how to do that with Redis
so I'm pretty sure based on the fact
that he was proposing it that you can do
it I'm not exactly sure the best way to
do that there's a hand back up here yeah
okay so is there any concern of network
blocking and I didn't hear the second
part of that yeah you mean okay so let
me try to understand your question so
with the network actually end up
becoming the blocking element of the
query yeah so this is not an area of my
strength but Redis does support
pipelining of Network calls to the Redis
server so what that means is in the
client that you use if you want to use a
client to talk to Redis the server it
can actually queue up the requests and
then send them to the server to get the
data back and it does it in a way that
actually speeds up the overall
transactions or the operations I
honestly don't know whole I know what's
going on there basically what the what's
happening is you've got so many requests
coming in the database may actually be
fast enough to handle those requests but
the network may not be able to handle
those requests so in that particular
case you can help the network out by
saying well rather than sending one over
at a time let's queue them up and we'll
send over ten at a time for example and
then Redis is so fast that it can easily
handle the ten and respond and faster
than it would have taken to send over
ten over individually so that's how
Redis would handle that and I believe it
actually does a good job of solving that
problem yes
yes
so I actually don't know very much about
how the open-source Redis does that
because it's fairly new and I haven't
studied that part of it yet so I can
only tell you how Redis labs would do
that I'll keep it short essentially what
happens is Rattus labs would do two
things number one it would use up all
the memory for that physical server
except if it determines that it would
have better performance by using
multiple cores on that physical server
then it would do that it would split up
the memory to multiple cores based on
performance and then it would
essentially automatically shard for you
okay
so it automatically figure that out you
don't have to figure that out like which
data to put on which server is that does
that answer your question okay yeah all
right I can't go yes in the back there
so the best way I can answer that
question is that you can install a
client on each one of your servers your
application servers that can maintain a
hash of where the data is actually
stored so that the data the requests are
not going through a proxy and then to
the serve the this the node that has the
the data on it instead the the web
application can connect directly to the
node that has the the data on it and
therefore it's there's a no shared
anything I shared nothing architecture
and therefore it should scale fairly
linear does that make any sense I don't
have a good answer for that I don't
again like network operations is not my
specialty but yeah at some point the
network can become a problem and I I
know that they there are optimizations
that have been made to handle that like
I said before with the pipelining but I
don't know anything more than that
honestly I can tell you that in some
cases for example storing session data
it actually makes a lot of sense to
store the data on a separate server and
not have it be stored on the web servers
themselves because otherwise you're
having to do all that network traffic
just to keep an updated cache on all the
servers so keeping it stored on a
separate server actually makes a lot of
sense all of your web servers can talk
to the same cache for session data but
there may be certain circumstances
perhaps if you're you know doing some ad
serving or high performance trading or
something like that where you want to
have your cache on all of the servers
and that's probably going to be a custom
setup that you would do yourself ok so I
can't really see back there but I don't
see any more hands so I think
we'll just call it a day
and like I said before wealth by the way
thank you for your questions if I didn't
answer any of your questions fully I'd
be happy to go and get more details for
you and I do have shirts so if you would
like a t-shirt come on down I'd be happy
to give you one other than that thank
you very much